[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent industrie verte pour une
transition au plus près des territoires
lundi 9 octobre 2023 députés et
sénateurs sont parvenus à un accord sur
le projet de loi relatif à l'industrie
verte en commission mixte
paritaire ce texte définitivement adopté
par le Sénat le 11 octobre entend
favoriser les imp ation d'usine en
France dans le cadre de la transition
écologique et faciliter le financement
de cette
transition le compromis entre les deux
Chambre reprend la plupart des apports
du Sénat notamment sur le rôle des
collectivités en matière de
réindustrialisation la rationalisation
des procédures administratives
incombants aux entreprises et la
valorisation des friches à l'article 9
qui avait provoqué de vives protestation
de la part des associations d'élus les
sénateurs ont ainsi obtenu l'assurance
pour les communes de ne pas se voir
imposé par l'état de projets industriels
d'intérêt national majeur de type
gigafactories les régions dotées par ce
texte de nouvelles compétences en
matière de développement économique
territorial seront également consulté et
pourront elles-mêmes signaler des
projets d'intérêt national majeur en
parallèle le Sénat s'est attaché à
garantir l'intégrité environnementale du
projet de loi des dispositions
présentant des risques environnementaux
importants en matière de gestion des
déchets ont été supprimées ou ajusté un
compromis a également été trouvé sur les
obligations de couverture des parkings
et bâtiments en panneaux photovoltaïques
permettant d'envoyer un signal fort en
faveur d'une production de panneaux sur
le sol européen enfin le texte assure un
meilleur équilibre entre une orientation
plus active des investissements vers le
tissu productif d'un côté et une
protection renforcée des épargnants de
l'autre notamment en redéfinissant le
périmètre d'investissement du Plan
d'épargne avenir climat créé par le
texte si leex ainsi enrichi constitue
une avancée le Sénat soulligne qu'il ne
s'agit que d'un petit pas vers la
réindustrialisation de la France c'est
désormais tout l'appareil productif
qu'il faut mettre en ordre de marche
vers la transition
écologique pour en savoir plus consulter
le site internet du
Sénat